la ministra de sanidad española ha
anunciado este viernes que España
exigirá una pcr negativa o la Pauta
completa de vacunación frente al cobi 19
a Los viajeros que lleguen desde china
además se realizará antes de antígenos a
pasajeros provenientes del país asiático
en los aeropuertos de Madrid y Cataluña
las únicas dos regiones españolas con
vuelos directos desde y hacia el País
España apuesta así por la celeridad
frente al llamado a la coordinación
hecho por la Unión Europea que el jueves
afirmó que las pruebas diagnósticas o
restricciones a personas procedentes de
China no estaban justificadas para el
conjunto del bloque por las altas tasas
de vacunación en la población y porque
aún no se ha detectado ninguna variante
que no esté ya en el viejo continente
este tema crea división entre los 27
Italia que fue el primer país de Europa
en anunciar restricciones asegura que
debido a la libre circulación de
pasajeros en la Unión Europea si las
medidas no son conjuntas no sirven De
nada Francia por su lado aseguró que
sigue de la evolución de los casos en
China pero que solo impondrá medidas en
coordinación con sus socios europeos sin
embargo mientras que Manuel macron pidió
al gobierno francés que se proteja a la
población la embajada de Francia en
China a través de un tuit el martes
anunció que los chinos serán recibidos
con los brazos abiertos en suelo francés
bastante discordia al parecer sus cita
este tema por su lado el comité de
seguridad de sanidad europeo Se reserva
reimponer medidas de control Si fuera
necesario también el director regional
para Europa de la Organización Mundial
de la Salud recomienda actuar con
cautela para no discriminar a nadie